Dr. Zakir, could you first explain to us
how is the beginning of the Islamic
month determined?
We find
that whenever the blessed month of
Ramadan approaches,
we find a lot of concerns, debates,
arguments, and different opinions as far
as when does this month begin and end.
And we have different people giving
their own opinions, etc.
But as far as
the beginning of the Islamic month is
concerned, Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala is
very clear in the Quran that it is based
only and only on the sighting of the
moon.
The moment you sight the new moon, the
Islamic month begins.
And Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Baqarah, chapter number two,
verse number 189,
they ask thee concerning the new moons.
Say,
these are signs, marked,
fixed for a period of time for the
affairs of men and for pilgrimage.
Allah is very clear that the moment you
sight the new moon,
the Islamic month begins. And Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam has made it
clear in various sahih hadith.
It's mentioned in Sahih Bukhari,
volume number three, in the book of
fasting, hadith number 1909, Abu
Hurairah, may Allah be pleased with him,
he said,
Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam,
Abu Qasim, that was another name, may
Allah be pleased with him, he said,
that fast
when you see
the crescent
of Ramadan. Fast when you see the new
moon that is of Ramadan.
And you will stop fasting when you see
the crescent, that is the new moon of
Shawwal.
And
if the sky is overcast, that means you
cannot see the moon, then complete 30
days of Sha'ban.
And Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
was very particular
to count especially the days in the
month of Sha'ban so that
he could be sure when is Ramadan going
to begin.
And it's mentioned in Sunan Abu Dawud,
volume number two,
in the book of fasting, hadith number
2318,
Hazrat Aisha, may Allah be pleased with
her, she says that Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam
was the most careful in counting the
days of the month of Sha'ban.
And whenever he saw the new moon of
Ramadan, he used to start fasting.
And if
he could not see the new moon because of
cloudy weather, etc., then he used to
complete 30 days of Sha'ban.
Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam was
particular in counting the days of
Sha'ban so that he could know exactly
when does the month of Ramadan start.
And as far as witness is concerned,
whether the moon is sighted or not,
the beloved Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam said, it's mentioned in
Sunan Nisai, book of fasting, hadith
number 2118,
the Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu Alaihi
Wasallam said,
when two just Muslims
sight the moon, when they give shahada,
then fast
or stop your fast.
That means when two just Muslims give
their verdict,
you can start your fasting, start the
month of Ramadan, or stop your fasting
in the month of Ramadan.
Therefore, two witnesses are required
for
testifying whether the month of Ramadan
has started or ended.
But
there are other group of scholars who
also say that one witness is sufficient
to start the month of Ramadan based on
the hadith of Sunan Abu Dawud,
volume number two, in the book of
fasting, hadith number 2335, where
Abdullah ibn Umar, may Allah be pleased
with him, he said that when people were
seeing the moon,
trying to find the new moon of Ramadan,
I told to the Prophet that I had seen
the new moon.
The Prophet fasted and he commanded all
the people to fast. So based on this one
witness alone,
most of the scholars, they say that for
the beginning of the month of Ramadan,
one witness is sufficient. If two,
that's preferable, but one is
sufficient. And for the end of the month
of Ramadan,
then two witnesses are required.